YES!
THE PEDAL TO THE METAL ALLABOUT
LAMELO.
MAN.
OH,
THIS WAS A GREAT UNDERHAND BY
LaMELO.
GREAT TIMING
I DIDN'T SEE THAT COMING.
>> Dell: AT THE TO
HORNETS, LOOKING FOR A FOURTH
CONSECUTIVE WIN. SO WERE GORDON
HAYWARD, HE IS IN  WHAT
TO PLAY FAST AND THEY HAVE
PERSONNEL WHO CAN P: WOW.
DELLTO PLAY, TWO
POINTS CHARLOTTE
>>.
JOB STAYING WITH HIM. BY RID
BISMACK GOT THE REBOUND ROM
THE FIRST HALF TO THE
SECOND HALF
>> Eric: THE BALL IS
LAMELO GETS THE
HE HAS HIT A PAR.
LaMELO GETS THE SWITCH.: LAMELO.
WORKED ALL NIGHT LONG.
ROOKIE FOR NEW ORLEANS.
LAMELOEIGHT CONSECUTIVE SHOTS UL
THAT ONE FELL.
DEL: LAMELO' WHAT ARE THEY THIN?
LAMELO
HURRY. 2EDMAGIC BY 3 AGAIN, LAT.